I can't say I've lived in Japan until I've experienced the following.Until I
start creating content about Japan.Until I
can complete the mission without hesitation in teamLab's Museum of Light.I
can place a fixed order at Yoshinoya.  Until I
slacked off as a tour guide for my friend when he came to visit Japan.
Until I matched with a so-called foreigner hunter at the Sky Tree.
Until I
realized that his only purpose was English conversation. I found out later that he was sleeping with my friend.  Right
after I said I've never been homesick, I started feeling extremely homesick until I passed on the
souvenirs I received from others as if I had bought them myself.Incidentally,
this is
called the souvenir loop.
Until I eat ramen with beer at another restaurant even though I'm
full from beer and ramen, until I
blame Japan for all of my problems,
and until someone points out that wrong idea and I
get angry.
Until I'm like, "This guy just
used a foreigner card." Until he finds out his trick and finds himself in a really
awkward situation.
Until he's sitting on the other side of a Starbucks,
glaring at the foreigner who's robbing him of his sense of specialness.
Bonus points will be given to people who take pictures of cherry blossom viewing and upload them to Twitter while still inside,
complaining about the crowds at the cherry blossom viewing event.  Why
didn't you come and sit next to me until I had that experience? Is it because I'm a foreigner? Because I wouldn't be
comfortable if someone spoke to me in English. Why did I
think I could speak English? Because I'm a foreigner.
Yes, it's
perfect in my head.  Until I fail to explain wabi-sabi even though I know it,
Until I watch the end credits of a movie that isn't even Marvel,
Until I can't use the hidden towel in a hot spring,
Until I can play a crane game in one shot, Until I spend 2,000 yen.  You ca
n't succeed in the crane game
until you have experience It's funny that you go so far as to
make fun of your own country in order to increase your favorability with the Japanese That's why the
cup is so
big Everyone has guns, everyone
has them That's right,
NHK  Until I don't care about the feelings of other people Until I
forget everything I learned through tears of blood Until I realize that it's not the first time I've said something like this
Until I realize that I'm good at Japanese Until I
realize that I'll be saying this forever